hey 42 here frogs legs were eaten in
Britain for 7,000 years before they were
eaten in France
welcome to Oliver Cromwell was dug off
and beheaded two years after his death
the ancient Egyptian word for cat was
pronounced meow
94% of terrorist campaigns failed to
achieve a single one of their strategic
goals cricket produce their iconic
chirping by rubbing their four wings
together the sound is then heard by the
female via ear like structures on her
front legs 95% of the spiders in your
house have never been outside the daddy
longlegs flosses after meals by pulling
each of its eight legs through its jaws
the most difficult tongue twister in
English is pad kid poured curd pulled
Cod the body of the sea otter has a
pouch across the front where it keeps
rocks to break open shellfish the
lawnmower is the most dangerous item in
the garden the second most dangerous is
the flowerpot eels can live inside
shark's hearts in Japan the number 42 is
considered to be unlucky because four
and two while pronounced as she and knee
which can be translated to death the
kite as we know it today was first
invented in China between 468 and 376 BC
the largest known star in the universe
is V Y Canis Majoris it sits nearly
5,000 light-years from Earth and is more
than 1,500 and 40 times larger than our
Sun if the rest of the planet freshwater
disappeared there would be enough left
in Lake Baikal in Russia to supply the
whole of humanity for 50 years the three
Russian cosmonauts whose spacecraft
depressurize just before we entry in
1971 are the only human beings to have
ever died outside the Earth's atmosphere
thanks for the view subscribe for more
for teaser